You might just want to sneak up so you don’t
sprinkle any dirt at the bottom of this place
where we turned it over.
Yeah ok.
Look at that soil, it is all cake looking.
Yeah it is.
Where are we?
Look up yonder. To the left
Oh wow!
Ok, let me get the soil before you start whacking
ok?
Oh yeah.
Salt blast covered.
Here we can see evidence of the mining. Now
this mine closed, many years ago.
The bottom is glass-covered Houston.
Yeah, white glass.
So if we look into the quarry in the normal
daylight in the absence of the snow it would
look a bit like a lunar landscape.
No the black stuff that is that stuff is crystal,
that is the crystal in rocks,
Now I say that for one specific reason because
during the Apollo programme the astronauts
, they came back from the moon with bucket
loads and bucket loads of moon rock and dust.
That part of it is.
Very good.
And upon analysis they were really, really
surprised to find that there were a number
of elements including Yttrium which existed
at a much much higher abundance on the moon
Which happens to be the deepest penetration
that bowler made.
So we are in Ytterby in Sweden and it’s
a really nice day and we have come to the
Ytterby Quarry, or Ytterby Groover, which
is actually the birthplace for 4 of the elements
and really the one we are going to talk about
now is this one right here yttrium. It was
first discovered in this quarry from a really
horrible black lump of mineral which people
thought was coal. And over a period of 40
years from the late 1700s on, some scientists
over in Arbo did a lot of work in refining
this material and they found a new earth or
yttria. Ok this was yttrium and oxygen and
they couldn’t get the oxygen out by using
traditional reductive methods, metal making
methods like burning with carbon and charcoal.
So the yttria survived and it was known for
about 40 years before the German scientist
Volla, decided to react the yttria with a
much more reactive element, potassium. The
potassium wrestled and ripped out the oxygen
and he made yttrium metal for the first time.
Yttrium its used in a whole range of different
things, it’s used in semi conductors, where
there is yttrium, barium, copper oxides, the
1-2-3 complexes that we know of and it’s
used for a whole range of applications. It’s
used in laser technologies to make very intense
pulses of light, for technologies like CDs
and LEDs etc., etc., but a massive, massive
area.
Another activity of another use for yttrium
is actually in the use of yttrium oxisulphide
which is used as an additive in glass it makes
glass really tough, like bullet proof glass
it makes it very shock resistant and very
very resistant towards temperature changes,
so it is a very useful additive in glasses
and glassy materials.
Make sure you don’t fall over the rock
So yttrium itself is a really quite nice lustrous
soft metal from group 3 of the periodic table,
it burns really readily in an oxygen rich
atmosphere and reacts quite well with water
in the atmosphere as well. So you have to
be very careful with yttrium because it oxidises
and it is really quite easy to destroy.
That’s Yttrium metal, just as turnings.
So we have to handle this under nitrogen because
generally it will form an oxide layer and
then you would not be able to do any chemistry
with it.
Yttrium is an element which is not again particularly
widely studied in chemistry, much less so
than its neighbour zirconium, and but again
it’s an area where chemists now are starting
to focus rather more.
If it is really finely divided then it might
burst into flames, in fact, all metals if
they are finely divided they are quite likely
to spontaneously combust.